Okay, so, for more efficient partitioning, that is actually not true.
We have not been touching the partition function, the partition function does not have
anything to do with the dynamic launches that I can do the recursive parallelism.
Launching on the fly, however, yes.
That does substantially contribute because I don't have to keep returning back to the CPU to do my launch forming.
That means I'm communicating less data and it means that my
launch occurs immediately when I need it,
instead of waiting around until that particular wave of launched is finished.
Simple code, while convenient and I can probably maintain it faster,
is not the reason why it actually runs any faster.
And finally, greater GPU utilization is probably the cause for the greatest of speedups.
By launching on the fly, I'm making sure my GPU is always busy, so when one partial sort finishes,
it creates 2 more immediately, keeping my GPU fully stacked up and busy with work.
It streams more work for my GPU at one time, and my sort ends up faster end-to-end.
In fact, when I've written this program in dynamic parallel form and then host launched form,
I see a pretty much exactly factor of 2 speed up between the two.